だからこの勉強の場合は
私個人の意見では 戒律の学問はそんなに難しくないんだけどね
法律ですから 法律的な立場と
この心理的な働きだけちょっと掴めばササササーッと勉強できますけどね
でもテキストあるわあるわ
いろんな問題に もうあのお坊さんは「いえ
そうではない これはこれでこうで 」「
いいえ これではない これはこうだ 」
とかもういろいろ問題があったりとかね
それでミャンマーとスリランカ当たったり戦ったりするし
で タイとまたスリランカ戦った
いつでもスリランカと当たってますからね
いろいろお互いにもいろんな話やったり
喧嘩したりしますけど
でもそれは仏教の中の喧嘩だから
別に誰一人もお互いに悪い意味は全く持ってないんです
そこはすごく美しいところで
同じ宗教な宗派の中で
あるポイントについて私はこう思います
それ自分が一杯いろんな証拠を出しちゃう
他の他のお坊さんも私はやっぱりこういう意味ですよと言って
またいっぱい証拠を出したりしてね
なかなかどちらが出しても一度も解決は出てこないんです
ほとんどこの僧侶になってから
この大きさにも長い間
我々が生まれる前に 10年もっとかな
ずっと僧侶になったんです
衣の大きさはどうしますかとか
色はどうかと ああだこうだとかね
別にじゃあ紫色でいいということじゃなくて
同じ黄色い色なんですけど
その中でも厳密に あの
じゃあお釈迦様はどんな色で決めたんですかと
なぜそういう問題が生まれるかというと
パーリ語でカーサーワンという意味しか言葉しかないし
カーサーワンというのはまあまあそれなりにちょっと意味がありますけどね
ちょっと日本語の言葉で表現ないんだけど
黄色いという意味でもないんですね
黄色の場合はパーリ語でピータンという別の言葉があるんですね
カーサーワンというのは
いわゆる 何色かな 色の意味じゃないんですね
いわゆる 染める 染めるというような意味なんですね
だからそこでどのように染めますかというと
植物の葉っぱと木の皮と木の根とかね
そういうものを持ってきて切って
沸騰するというかね 水に入れて全部茹でて
もうそれに衣を入れて色を染めなさいと
そういう風にいろんなものを集めて作った色を考えているんですね
でも青くしようと黄色くしようと思ったら
すごく あの 何て言いますか
いろいろ職業の技が必要なんですね
自然のものを集めて青い色に染めようとかね
日本で有名な色を何て言いますか
藍染めとかね そういう風に決まってる色にするのは
これ誰にでもできるものじゃないんですね
それは大変な技術が必要なんですね
衣の場合は技術はもう全く無用と
ということだから その色決まっている色なんですね
そこでみんなまあこういう色では良くない
こういう例えば真っ黄色の色は良くないとか
真っ赤な色は良くないとかね
自分の国である時期では赤い色の衣を着るとかなりお坊さんたち批判される時もあったんだから
すごく もうまあそれは政治的なこともあったかもしれませんだけどね
まあ政府はいろいろ悪いことをした
それでお坊さんたちが反対しちゃって
でお坊さんたちが政府に決めてくれたんです
共産主義者だと で それを決めていただいたんだから
なかなか赤色の衣は着られなくなっちゃったというか
着たらその当時の党を応援している人々にいろいろいじめられたりもしたことがあったし
そこである宗教がね 仏教を破壊しようと思って
自分たちが仏教の本文の宣言作っちゃったんですね
いくらか勉強してる人なら
だから自分たちがすごい黒に近い色
ものすごい汚れてる色の衣を着て
何か下をジーっと見てゆっくり歩く
皆様も歩く瞑想やってるような感じで
それこそ正しいんだと
それで一般の人々は素晴らしいお坊さんたちだと思って
そこら辺に行って いろいろこの坊さんたちは否定することが目的で
一般のそれは大変ダメージに
一時期はダメージ受けたんだけどね
それでその色を着てるお坊さんだけお坊さんだってなっちゃう
そこでは他の宗教団体やってた仏教ではなかったんだけどね
カラクリだともうバレたところで
まあそこはまあなくなったんだけど
それからまあこんな色に近い色
お坊さんたちは着ていますから,普通のお坊さんたちにもこんな俺の近い色を着なくなっちゃったんで着られなくなっちゃったんで
そういうふうな まあいろいろ問題が起きたりね
まあなんかバラバラらしいんですけどね
仏教の世界でもね 今が旬だからね
そういうことも起こるんです
とにかく戒律の世界でも
やっぱり 大変な大きな世界で
この分析としては この外の影響を受けて心が汚れる
汚れる場合もあるし 汚れない場合もある
その場合はどちらかにするかと心を育てるか
育てるまで外の世界をコントロールするかということで
外の世界をコントロールすることを戒律にしている
で 戒律の中でも自分の心はどれほど清らかであろうとも
やることはできない仕事あります
それはもうまた別な戒律
それはそういう性的な行為やら殺生することやらね
例えばもう悟った人は殺生してもいいんじゃないかと
別に心汚れてないんだからって不可能なんです
悟ったならば なぜならば
まず心を汚す 相手を殺すという気持ちが生まれてこなきゃ行動しないでしょう
ですから 悟った人は殺生はしません
いわゆる殺生することは不可能です
その場合はこの人に訴えられて
お釈迦様が言うのは その人は罪を犯すことは不可能であると
不可能なのです そこで一般の人々には
もうそういう戒律は厳密に守らなくちゃいけない
心から心が汚れてする行動は永久戒律なんです
心が汚れてそれからする行動
汚れた心でする行動は永久戒律で
行動から汚れる場合は永久戒律じゃないんです
なぜならば 心は完全に完璧になっちゃったら
その行動から汚れることはまたない
そういうふうに戒律を認識する
それはローカヴァッチャ
パンニャティヴァッチャと仏教では 2つに分けて
ローカヴァッチャっていうのは普遍的に間違っている行動
パンニャティヴァッチャっていうのは
お釈迦様はやめなさいと決めたんだから間違っていると
釈尊に言われたんだからやめましょうと
で 認識があって アビダンマと戒律はまるっきり合わない学問ですからね
そこら辺はやめましょう
で このシステムで今日は私は全部ワードとしていたんだけど
いくらか我々には人間の心の在り方がわかるんです
これは目に何か触れた瞬間のことだけ
目に何か触れた瞬間にこのようなことは生まれる
でもこのセットではちょっとした間違いがあるんですが
これってどうやって解決するんですか
これはいつでもまた勉強し直さなきゃいけないんだけど
本当はただアーラマナ二つは生まれないはずなんです
で そこは世の皆さんにわかるかもしれませんだけど
このある物質が生まれると
生まれた瞬間でその物質は増えないんですね
体の 次の瞬間から そこで五重書いてあるところで
一番目ではもう生まれた瞬間でしょうし
十七刹那はもう死の瞬間だから見れないはずなんですね
ですから これはちょっとどうかなと
ただアーラマナ一つに書く場合も二つに書く場合もありますし
ですから それ どこを編集すればいいかわからないです
もう一つポイントがありまして
それはちょっとちょっときめ細かいことだから
後でちょっと読み直します
で じゃあ私たちにこのものを見て見えたでしょ
何かを いつ見えたんですかというと
この見えた時期があった時だけなんですね
元気でいた時だけなんですね
この一刹那で生まれて十七刹那でその見えたものは死んじゃうんです
そこで見たという認識が生まれたのは
そのものがあった時だけ
これ大変なポイントです
私はものを知るたびにそのものがあるんです
そのものがない時は知らないんです
だから例えば見たのは花にしたでしょうに
花が現れて それからいて消える
また現れていて消えるでしょ
生と住と滅でしょ で 生の瞬間は見えない
住の時は見える 滅の時また見えない
その時は心は何も認識しない
寝ているんです それでまた住の時また見る
また住の時見る また住の時見ると
そこで じゃあ住の時 住の時
住の時見たんではないかと見ると
その間は見てないと気がつくはずなんですけど
有分身だから何も気がつかないんですね
このヴィパッサナー瞑想でそこら辺心には大胆なプログラム
何て言いますか 変え替えをするんです
そこを見させてあげる
あげようと 見るものは生まれることと消えること
それで消えることを見始めたら
それはヴィパッサナーの智慧の一番高いところ
バンガン・ヴィパッサナー・ニャーナと言って
次の悟るしかないんです
道が もう戻らない 本人が本当に悟りたいという気持ちでやっちゃうと悟るんです
まあ後にしましょうという気持ちがあったらもう生まれませんだけど
ですから私たちはこの修行によって
この この物質のなくなる瞬間をつかもうつかもうとするんです
なくなる瞬間をつかめるようになっちゃったら
これすごい大胆な智慧なんです
ですから こういうプロセスはほんのちょっと逸らしちゃうんです
これ大変なことです でも決して非科学的なものでも妄想の世界でもないんです
だから世の中の瞑想とは違う
世の中の瞑想は妄想させて幻覚を起こしちゃって
何とかしようとイメージを何とか作ったりして
最初から教えてあげると
我々は最初から何も教えてあげないで
ただありのまま見ていてくださいと
それからどんどん智慧を包んでもらって
どんどんこの この見るプロセス
ほんの僅かに外れてもらうと
まあこれはありえないことなんで
その悟る過程を後で説明します
じゃあ今のところで説明しちゃうと
で この同じ式がまた生まれるでしょうね
ここ一二三四と  [音楽]で見えたものが
一瞬はいて ここで十七のセッスナで死んでまた生まれ始めるでしょ
いわゆる十八番目のセッスナで新しい式の初めなんです
そこで十七セッスナの式はとは全く違う式が十八セッスナの式なんです
生まれたばっかりだから
もしこの下に書いた心の流れを擦れてみたら
ちょっと擦らしちゃったってするとジャワナとかサンパティッチーナとか
例えば十七でサンパティッチーナがおったからしちゃったらどうなるんでしょうか
式の十七のセッスナの時はおったかにするでしょう
決めちゃった 何に決めちゃった？そこでもう死んじゃったことにする
それに過ぎてジャワナが生まれなくちゃいけないんです
即興心が死んだものに過ぎない
これに関係なく そこはここで持ったことすることこそがヴィパッサナーの一番高い智慧のところなんです
でも普通の心の法則ではそれはありえないと
まあそこは難しい これはちょっとレベルの高いアビダンマの方に入りますからね
まああの またまたセットいっぱいありますから
このサマーディの心や悟りの心とかね
ですからこの悟りっていうのは
まあ一応ちゃんと科学化しているんです
アビダンマでは 大雑把な
なんとなく宗教的な神秘体験みたいなもんじゃなくて
きちんと科学化しているんです
で じゃあ元に戻ります
で ものは見ました 即行心という心が働き出しました
ここで可笑縁が生まれたと
それで次の瞬間 心はどうなりますかというと
またバヴァンガになるんです
またウブンになってしまうんです
だから認識ワンセット終わったらウブンシンになる
一秒間ものを見ちゃうと
何回ウブンシンになるかともわかったもんじゃないんです
なぜウブンシンになるかというと
ここでエネルギーは切れてるでしょうと
十七セッスナで色からぶつかったエネルギーはもう切れたんですから
切れた瞬間で心は情報ないんだということでウブンシンになる
また情報が入っちゃったら
またウブンシンが切れて切断して認識が生まれる
ですからこういうセット書くと
可笑縁の次に必ずウブンシンを書かなくちゃいけない
だから 分身で始めて分身で認識ワンセット終わっちゃうんです
そこにも波なんで分身から始めて認識波が生まれて
また分身に戻って また上へ上がって
また元に戻って 波の論はずっとあります
どこに そこら辺何か分からないところございますか
即行心は有為沙 also 即行心になるんですよね
そう  有為の有為沙 also とか
弊途のある有為沙 also
因がある有為沙 also の場合も
人間にもそれは起こるんですか？起こって
この場合は人の生地の有為沙 also とか
それも人間には起こる
人界 人間の世界でも起こる
有為沙 also は人間に起こりません
有為沙 also は阿羅漢にだけ起こるんだからね
じゃあ善心か不善心か
どっちかです そうです
それは避けられない 人間には有為沙 also はできません
人間じゃなくて 生命には有為沙 also は不可能です
悟った人にだけ 阿羅漢になった人だけ
預流果になっても不可能なんです
一来果 歩限果になっても不可能です
その場合は極大の場合で
その大衆演の場合には過去分中に極端に増えて
その場合はタダーランマの方がここの解説読みますと一つということがなくて
必ず一人というのは二体というふうに決まっているらしいですね
だからすぐに即成の後にまたみんなに
だからタダーランマが二つですから
私はこの大アティマハンターラマないですか
これ極大 極大でしょ この場合もちょっと計算が合わなく
合わないなと感じてるんだから
どうしようかと ここで間違ったでしょうと思いますけどね
0から始まってると 0
から 0 のところが気になってて
色々 それは1から  そうすると 0 からで 18 になっちゃいます
0 から始めたら 18 でしょうね
それは分かります 数字的に
でも 17 セスナしか生きていないんだから
1 セスナは生で 17 セスナ滅でしょうに
この 0 を入れたことは
この空間を数えれば 17 に
そうですか  1番下になるってことなんですか？ そうそう
空間数えれば 17 です
なるほど そうすると合いますね
0から1の間 1から2の間っていう風に数える
その方が正しいでしょうね
そうすると 0 が必須になっちゃうね
0 から 1 は生の瞬間ですね
生の瞬間後は無分身で全然さっぱりわかってないんだと
1 から 2 の間はもう分かり始めたんだから
もう過去分じゃなくて新道童幼心ですね
なるほど そうするとあっち二つ空きが出てきます
僕はこの点取っちゃったところを間違ったんですね
この間の部分ですね それで次の問題なんですけど
それでそれただ目に情報が触れた瞬間だけで
その時でも目に起こるのはこれチャックヴィンヤーナだけ
だからそれ見たとかやっぱりわからないんです
いわゆる触れた反応をチャック・インジャーナが受ける
もうチャック・インジャーナが
いわゆる心が反応する
反応が領事心が受けることは領事心と言うんですね
反応にすべて起こる心には覚動心と言うんですね
それによって心が流れるんだから
それにも即病心と言うんです
ですから どこで本当に見たことになるんでしょうかね
私だけの知識で見たことにはどこでなるんですかね
本当は人間の知識ではこれぐらいでは見たことにならない
それから心で感じられちゃうんです
ですから 何億回もこういう風なセットが生まれてこないと
花見ましたとかね 出てこないんです
これは認識のわずかな
一番わずかな瞬間のことなんで
こちらで言っているのは
この十七に分けた間だけど
十七の間に分けたんだけど
これはもう一番わずかな瞬間
これ以上認識の短い瞬間がないんです
その瞬間の中でも心はこういうふうにたくさん生まれて消えていっちゃうんです
そういうセットが何億回生まれると
やっと見たような気がするんです
そこで結局そのセットでは自由意識がない
で 目に触れた 受けた 反応しました
確定して それに走った
確定した状態と違う方向へ走ることができませんから
ですから 心を育てていない人にとってはもう決まっていることで
それで自由が出てくるのは
意の働きの世界でなんですね
意識働かせちゃうと 自由が出てくるんです
自分の私個人の経験で言うと
みんなたまにあれは綺麗だ
あれはすごい良いものだと言って
向こうはもう無粋 何が綺麗ですか
何かすごいという感じなんですね
そういうことでみんな一斉になって言うが言うことで
やっぱりみんなの意見も理解しなくちゃいけないんだと思って
それでまたさらにさらに頭の中でいろいろ角度を変えたり
いろんなことをいろんな工夫して工夫して殺したところで
やっとなるほど綺麗だというふうに出てくるんですね
ですから 見た目では綺麗か綺麗じゃないかということは出てこない
それで工夫してみんなの流れの方向にも合わせてみようと思っちゃうと
そのみんな感じる感覚というかね
それをわかってわかるようになっちゃうんです
ですから 心はそれなりにコントロールしちゃうと
もう綺麗で見るか汚くで見るか
随分勝手にできるんです
だからもうもっと即的な例で言えば
もう部屋の掃除したくないんだと
ということだったら あっ
なかなか綺麗ですねと
私は大体正直なもんなんです
もう掃除機したくない場合は
本当に別に汚いんだけど
やっぱりまあ嫌だっていう感じではいないんです
まあなかなか綺麗じゃないのっていう感じですごい気持ちよくいるんですね
そこでなんかつまらなくなって掃除でもしてやろうかなと思っちゃうんです
思った瞬間で全部汚くなっちゃうんです
もう汚いんだと 汚れて汚れて嫌だと
それで片っ端からまあすごいきめ細かくうるさいほど掃除するんです
見えるところ 見えないところ
埃がたまるところ あーでも全部計算しながら
こういうところから空気来るんだから
こっちが埃溜まる こっちの溜まらない
こっちがよく吹いてこっちがという
そこまでやっちゃう その時はもう汚いと見るんですね
なぜならば掃除したいんだから
掃除したくないと思っちゃったら
まあもうなかなか綺麗じゃないかという風に
だから随分心っていうのは勝手なんですね
その場合は 勝手と言えば勝手なんですけど
自分自由自在なんですね
だから何か食べたくないなと思っちゃったら
美味しくないとなるんです
僕の場合は なんでこんなおいしくないものを食べなくちゃいけないのか
ですから 本当は食べたいんだけど
やっぱり食べ過ぎだからやめますというような
この 何て言いますか ストレスはないんです
なんでこんなもん食べなくちゃいかな
そんな感じなんですね
だから食べない方が気持ち良くて
それで何か食べたくなったら
どんな不味いものでも何のことなく食べるんですね
かえって逆に これはもう腐っているものであろうが
もう日にち経っているものであろうが
もうそんなもう関係なし
これはそれでも食べられるんですね
やっぱり美味しいですよ
これはやっぱり自分で食べたいと思うっていうことから
そういうふうに情報を解釈するんですね
だから 心の働きと実際の働きというのは全く別々だと
ということなんですけど
まあ悪く言えば勝手であって
もうちょっと色をね 白色を塗って言えば
かなり心は自由だと 心は自由だと言えるんですね
だからものすごいひどいうるさいところでも
居心地よくしようと思ったらすごい気持ちよくいられるんですね
で 逆もできるし 静かなところで気持ちよくしようと思ったら
すぐその環境にも心は合わせてしまう
とにかく心を合わせると
ものを合わせるんじゃなくて
心によって どうしてやり方
そのやり方なんです だから本気になって私に聞いたっても何の意味もないんです
これは美味しいか それは綺麗かと
僕には全然判断ないんです
僕にどっちにしてほしいと言ったら
本気でそうしてあげるんです
例えば 全く汚い もう醜い
くだらない絵があるんだと
本当はただの落書きだと
それを本当に立派な絵にしてほしいと言ったら
私はもうそういう思考を作ってあげることできます
見てくださいと こういう線がこういうふうに出ているんだ
これはこういう風に出ているんだ
こうこう見れば こういう風に見えるんではないかと
ですから これ何て言いますかね
だから僕に本当に正直なとこはね
あんた何を食べたいかというのは絶対答えられない質問です
で もう何がもうそういう好き嫌いは何ですか？何時に寝るかとかね
何時 1 日何時間寝るかとか
個人的なことを聞くでしょ
腹が立つんです 答えがないんです
勝手なんです その場合は
寝たければ僕は朝 8時でも寝られるし
12時でも真夜中 真夜中じゃなくて昼間 12時でも寝られるし
起きていたければもう何時でも関係なく起きていられるし
すぐ心変えるだけ 例えば 12時になったとこで
よし今日何かやるぞと思ったら
もう私にとってはそこはもう朝と同じなんですね
すごいもう気持ち全部変わってるんです
ですから この それは理解すればできるものなんですね
ものに 例えば夜だから人は眠くなるんだとかね
朝だから元気だとかね
そういうのは人間の俗世間のことであって
本当はそうじゃなくて
そういうのは心が決まっているもんなんです
そこをちょっと掴めれば
かなりの自由な世界が出てくるんです
ですから もう必ず毎日もう食べなくちゃいけないとか
そういうの私にはないんです
例えば朝起きて食べるものないんだと
じゃあ外行って買おうかな
めんどくさい もう行きたくないんだ
寒いんだからと思ったら
それだけのことで 朝も食べなかったんだからどうしよう
そこ出てこないんですね
何のことなく そこでそれからどんな仕事があっても
どんな体力使うことがあったっても
それはもうあれはまるっきり関係なく
そういうことをやって終わっちゃうと
その間は食べたい気持ちもないし
美味しいとも感じない
そこで疲れが溜まったところで
なんか体が自由に動かないとか
なんか食べた方がいいなと思っちゃったら
ああ美味しいとかね 美味しい何か食べようという
そこでもう初めて出てくるもんです
で それじゃなくて 客観的な世界に支配される世界ではね
管理世界ではね ちゃんと三食食べなくちゃいけない
もう六時間から八時間まで寝なくちゃいけないとかね
水分ここまで取らなくちゃいけないとか
ああだこうだとか 全部外から管理されてる
でもう自分の自由を捨てるという人々の方が多いんですね
だからこの まあそれは自分で実験しているだけなんで
そう言ってることは本当かないかと
実験してみたら まあやっぱりその通りだと
だから例えば映画があるんだと
その映画はすごい感動的で素晴らしいやと思ったっても
私はそう決めません どんな角度で見ようかなと
見る角度を自分で決めるんです
最初から向こう側が決まってる角度では見ない
だから同じ映画三回見たら三つの角度で見られるというかね
まあ一回で十分ですけどね
まあ二回は見ませんだけど
で まあその時はいろんな角度をささささっと入れ替えて入れ替えて入れ替えて入れ替えて
そういうの入れ替えちゃう
まあどうせ分かりやすく言えば
どこの方に入れ替えるというか
自分の都合のいい方に入れ替えちゃうんです
例えば映画は面白くないと
でも映画館はすごい綺麗で立派で居心地がいいんだったら
まあゆっくりリラックスして座っているという方向に角度を入れちゃうし
それで自分にとっては都合がいいでしょうに
で 立ったままで見なくちゃいけないと思ったら
立ってるのは疲れるでしょうに
そうすると映画の方に焦点を入れて
面白いですね すごいな
そこでこちらも忘れて
楽しかったと いつでも自分の都合のいい角度しか取らないと
私の都合悪い角度は作らない
そういう生き方はここら辺の働きをね
アビダンマを見ると簡単にできるもんなんです
で 今説明したのはこの極大対象の場合
目に入ったrūpa一粒は生まれてすぐ目に触れたんだから
ぶつかったんです 生まれたまんまで目に入り込んじゃったんだから
長い間目の中にいるんですね
十七セッツナカン それで心には結構
すげえ 何て言いますか
反応を起こすんです 心に起こす反応はここで重ねると客員だから
一 二 三 四五番目ですね
五番目の刹那でもう反応受けちゃうんですね
そこで それに沿って心が生まれちゃう
で 次に出てくるのはもう簡単に説明できると思います
大初縁マハンターランマナ
この生まれた瞬間で見ることは見るんじゃなくて
生まれたその一刹那の時
目に入り込まなかったと
すると この可笑縁が生まれることはできなくなるんですね
可笑縁というのはいつでも二つセットだと決めてるんです
理由はわかりません 私も
で 可笑縁っていうのはちょっと味わうことだから
で そこをできないと それには大初縁と言うんですね
マハンターランマニと
で どういうことかというと
同じリストで書きますが
例えばこのここら辺で生まれたとすると
もうちょっと前に 一つ前に生まれたとすると
ここをゼロで ここを1でここ2 3
こうなったら 目に触れたのは
2番目の刹那で 色が ルーパが2番目の刹那で目に触れたとする
そうするとこの心の流れはその通りに行くんですが
そこでジャガナが十六刹那で生まれて終わっちゃうんですね
ジャガナは十六刹那で
また一つの刹那があるんだけど
可笑縁は生まれなくなっちゃう
2つ生まれるんだから
先に物質が死んじゃうんです
そこでどうなるかというと
タダーランマナは消えちゃう
タダーランマナ消えちゃって
可笑縁消えちゃって そちらにウブンシンが 1つ生まれる
このこの間に で あの簡単なことなんです
そんなに難しいことじゃないんです
ほんの瞬間逸らしちゃうと可笑縁の代わりにウブンシン
可笑縁は 2つ入る余地がないんです
で あの それは心の流れのセットは十何に持ってきて
ルーパの流れ十何に持ってきて
この逸らすということなんですね
ワン刹那前に逸らしちゃうと
こっちは一刹那が残っちゃうんですね
心の流れで でも一刹那はカットしなくちゃいけないでしょ
でも 2つともカットしなくちゃいけない
箇所縁だから 箇所二つだから
それ二つもカットするんです
そうすると心の流れが短くなっちゃうんですね
一セッツナ短いんですね
その一セッツナを分身で埋め込んじゃう
埋め込んで埋め込んで十七にピッタリするんです
いわゆる十七セッツナ長い一本の物質に
いわゆる十七セッツナ長い一本の物質にちゃんと十七本の長い心の流れをつなげておく
それで擦らすたびにいろいろカットしなくちゃいけないんです
そこでこれ一セッツナ過ぎた時でしょ
じゃあ二セッツナ 二つのセッツナが過ぎたらどうなりますかというと
そこで心の流れのセッツナ十七ありますから
そこで最後の二つもありすぎだから
その二つもカットする
二つもカットできます
だからジャワナ即行心七つでこのセットが終わっちゃうんです
そこまで大所縁というんです
小所縁の場合はどうでしょうかと
それまた時間はないね
四時半ですから じゃあそこら辺まあゆっくり説述しましょう
それ終わったらアビダンマ持ち帰るところありますからね
[足音]